[Musica]
voi ve lo siete certamente chiesti ma vi
confesso come lo sono chiesto anch'io
che ci azzecca
l'empatia con la politica internazionale
che ci azzecca in un mondo di conflitti
libia yemen iran in questo momento
israele palestina trump con huawei trump
con l'iran
trump con la cina che ci azzecca in
questo mondo
l'empatia cioè la capacità di mettersi
nei panni degli altri
la capacità di accettare che rispetto a
uno stesso fatto con lo stesso fenomeno
qualcun altro
un'altra persona lo lega in modo diverso
lo vede in modo diverso e quel modo di
leggerlo di guardarlo e legittimo devo
considerarlo deve tenerne conto
che spazio a vi sarete chiesti in un
mondo di questo tipo
l'empatia che spazia in un mondo dove la
lettura prevalente nelle teorie della
politica internazionale è che le
relazioni fra stati come quelle fra gli
uomini sono regolati dalla homo homini
lupus dalla logica di prevalenza di
prevaricazione dall'interesse dalla
forza dal potere tutto l'opposto del
mettersi nei panni degli altri tutto
l'opposto del accettare che altri vedono
in modo diverso e in questo mondo
la prima lettura e da qui la domanda che
ci azzecca e che questa visione un po
romantica quasi ottimista dell'empatia
che post uopo potrebbero dovrebbe avere
un ruolo nella politica internazionale
ci pare molto lontana
un mondo dove accettiamo gli altri
accettiamo il loro punto di vista ci
vogliamo tutti bene e tutti vissero
felici e contenti è molto lontano
dall'esperienza della nostra vita
quotidiana è molto lontana dalla realtà
e quindi una frase come quella di obama
quando incontra il papa egli dice è la
mancanza di empatia che ci sta facendo
scivolare nella guerra ci sembra una
speranza un'espressione di ottimismo di
illusione ma non sicuramente qualcosa
che vediamo nei fatti così come un'altra
frase di un sociologo americano rifkin
che dice che solo attraverso l'empatia
globale l'empatia fra tutto il mondo
riusciremo affrontare tutte le cose
brutte del mondo la crisi economica il
degrado ambientale le guerre ma obama
con il papa rifkin in questa frase sono
degli inguaribili ottimisti dei
visionari degli illusi o nell'empatia
realmente c'è la panacea alla soluzione
un modo per affrontare problemi del
nostro mondo che non va nella direzione
giusta
cerchiamo di muoverci fra questi due
estremi
l'empatia come soluzione a tutto e
l'empatia come lo direbbero realisti
come qualcosa di inutile perché nel
mondo governano la forza la supremazia e
l'aggressività sicuramente possiamo dire
che l'aspirazione all'empatia a mettersi
nei panni degli altri è un tratto che
sempre cef nei rapporti fra stati voi
avrete visto queste immagini muffe ci
fanno sorridere sono i vertici del g20 o
i vertici dell'europa con i paesi
asiatici o l'europa con i paesi africani
e vediamo questi leader del mondo qui
c'è putin con bushiano immagini anni fa
in questi buffi abiti perché lo fanno lo
fanno perché si mettono letteralmente
nei panni degli altri nel panni del
paese che li ospita
è un modo simbolico per dire sposo la
tua cultura sono come te
cerco di esser come te un fatto
simbolico che vediamo in tante occasioni
ma il provare a mettersi nei panni degli
altri e il provare ad accettare di uno
stesso fenomeno una lettura diversa
aiuta
aiuterebbe sarebbe molto utile in molte
crisi ve ne cito brevemente alcuni
partiamo dall iran voi tutti sapete che
l'iran è da decenni in una situazione
difficile e ha creato situazioni
difficili dalla rivoluzione poi
tentativo di avere il nucleare
l'accordo di obama con l'iran e poi dopo
arriva trump cancella l'accordo e ora ci
sono sull'iran venti di guerra americani
e iraniani potrebbero nessuno lo
l'aspica arrivare di nuovo a un forte
confronto facciamo insieme l'esercizio
di empatia cioè di provare a vedere dal
punto di vista dell'altro la situazione
in questa crisi
provate per un secondo ad essere
iraniani sete iraniani e siete in quel
paese rosso circondato dal blu quel
paese rosso e l'iran è un paese sciita
che ha un certo sistema di governo che
non ci piace che non è democratico come
lo vorremmo ma è un paese sciita
circondato dal blu che sono paesi
sunniti ostili
l'iran è ostile al blu imu sono ostili
al rosso e in questi paesi ostili fra
questi paesi ostili
alcuni non sono sulle israele non è
sicuramente un paese islamico
questi paesi alcuni di loro il pakistan
sotto l'india israele hanno la bomba
atomica e sono in tensione con l'iran e
fra questi paesi ce n'è uno l'arcinemico
l'arabia saudita e questo paese l'arabia
saudita
da quando c'è trump ha il potere è
diventato il miglior amico dell'america
insieme a israele cioè i due nemici
dell'iran sono i maggiori migliori amici
dell'america
se voi foste iraniani vedreste la
crescita del nucleare cioè avere una
bomba anche volo una bomba nucleare come
la migliore assicurazione per la vita in
quel contesto molto difficile
provate ad esso a fare l'americano a
provare a metterli nel punto di vista di
un americano
un'americana di 50 anni o di 45 anni
quando era bambino vedeva ogni giorno le
immagini dei dipendenti dell'ambasciata
americana tenuti prigionieri in iran e
tutti i giorni si parlava di quello gli
iraniani sono quelli che rapiscono i
miei colleghi il papà del mio amico e i
soldati che sono lì se io guardo negli
stati uniti la televisione fox news
ogni volta che si parla di run anche per
parlare di un terremoto in in iran fanno
vedere le immagini di repertorio delle
bandiere americane bruciate dell'epoca
di ahmadinejad e io sono americano e
vedo un paese un popolo che distrugge
incendia la mia bandiera
e se poi vado su netflix e vedo homeland
questo una di queste serie ii il nemico
degli americani chi vuole uccidere il
presidente americano paul uccidere tutti
i deputati è l'iran viene presentato
l'iran ha anche come il colpevole
dell'attentato delle torri gemelle che
in realtà era stato fatto da persone
legate alla rabbia saudita pensate voi
di teheran sui nemici mali quindi io
americano cresco ad anti iran
io ero a miano cresco col timore allora
in questo contesto si arriva all
escalation che può portare al confronto
l'empatia è quella che ha esercitato per
un breve periodo obama cercando invece
di trovare un accordo per dire quali
sono le ragioni dell'iran
quali sono i nostri ragioni ma fate lo
stesso con la questione la russia la
russia invade lacrime a qualche anno fa
fatto gravissimo rompe una regola del
mondo
ma cerchiamo di capire non giustificare
le ragioni della russia la russia nel
1990 era circondata guardate la parte
centrale dove c'è ungheria polonia
bulgaria era tutto il suo confine era
fatto di paesi alleati era nel patto di
varsavia tutti amici
un po alla volta quei paesi guardate
questa slide sono diventati tutti i blu
perché sono diventati l'ungheria la
polonia la bulgaria paesi europei
una volta entrati nella nato sono
diventate
nell'europa sono diventati paesi nato e
la nato è nata per contrapporsi alla
russia dal punto di vista russo si sente
circondata e l'unico paese che ma anche
quell'azzurro qual è il paese azzurro
l'ucraina e l'ucraina e cosa fa tre anni
fa decide di guardare all'europa di
chiedere di entrare in europa
e qual è il film che si fa la russia se
entro in europa fra un anno sono nella
nato e io sono circondato da blu sono
accerchiata e quindi dal punto di vista
russo
quello era l'unico modo non
giustificabile scorretto per mantenere
un proprio interesse e salvaguardarlo
ma pensate all'empatia se ci fosse
empatia nella break prima si è parlato
di break sid l'abbraccio il disastro
della break che sembra un gioco dell'oca
e la dimostrazione della incapacità di
tutti gli inglesi in gran bretagna di
capire le ragioni dell'altro quelli che
vogliono uscire non capiscono le ragioni
di quelli che vogliono rimanere il
governo non capisce le ragioni dei di
quelli dell'europa vuole o cose
impossibili ma non capisce che l'europa
non può dare condizioni che la gran
bretagna sta chiedendo la may non riesce
a mettersi nei panni neanche dei suoi
parlamentari conservatori metà dei quali
vogliono uscire metà dei quali voglio
rimanere e soprattutto il governo di
londra non riesce a capire le
frustrazioni i drammi le ragioni degli
scozzesi o degli irlandesi che dopo la
break it avrebbero un problemi ulteriori
e quindi il risultato è che c'è un gioco
dell'oca impazzito perché nessuno è in
grado di porsi nei panni dell'altro e
trovare la nebbia la mediazione il punto
d'incontro ma c'è un esempio dove
capiamo quanto fu importante a un certo
punto da parte di qualcuno uscire dalla
fretta della lettura veloce e mettersi
nei panni degli altri
alcuni di voi lo ricorderanno nel 1983
un aereo coreano passa per sbaglio lo
sappiamo dopo sul territorio russo siamo
in piena guerra fredda i russi lo
prendono
piena guerra fredda grandi tensioni
c'era reagan che parlava di guerre
stellari della russia come impero del
mare i russi lo vedono arrivare lo
abbattono è un aereo passeggeri con 269
persone a bordo immediatamente gli
americani reagiscono con grande forza
perché i russi non dicono neanche quello
che è successo negano l'incidente gli
americani reagiscono organizzano
un'esercitazione nato dentro due mesi
molto potente
i russi vedono questa esercitazione nato
come un attacco alla russia danno
l'ordine di preparare le rampe di lancio
dei missili nucleari e si sfiora come a
cuba vent'anni prima
una guerra nucleare perché dico che
l'empatia tra è servita perché lo
sappiamo ora anni dopo che fu la
capacità di capire come stavano leggendo
i fenomeni altri che usarono le spie i
servizi segreti inglesi a fermare questo
grande dramma che stava accadendo in che
senso
gli inglesi si resero conto che non
c'era da parte di russi cattiva volontà
non volevano abbattere un aereo per far
partire una guerra avevano sbagliato
avevano sbagliato perché c'era la russia
stava gente dall'unione sovietica stava
già entrando in crisi c'erano pochissimi
soldi i radar non funzionavano quindi
quell'aereo è apparso sul territorio
russo
all'ultimo momento ed è apparso in uno
spazio del territorio russo dove c'è una
base di lancio di missili russi di prova
e quindi russian detto sta arrivando un
aereo sta arrivando proprio noi dove
dove noi abbiamo una base di lancio e la
lunga catena di comando della gerarchia
russa lancia dei messaggi che vanno dal
capitano che si va al colonnello e
colonello generale arrivano fino a mosca
a mosca andro pof il presidente è malato
è in ospedale
c'è un po di caos danno l'ordine di
sparare e poi come in tutte le dittature
coprono tutto per cinque giorni tutto
ciò al momento perché non c'era la
volontà e la capacità di mettersi nel
punto di vista dell'altro
il punto di vista di una dittatura al
fine della sua storia sembrava portare a
una lettura sbagliatissima i russi
stanno attaccando l'occidente e furono
mesi dei servizi segreti della thatcher
che corsero da reagan dicendo non stiamo
capendo niente hanno fatto un errore non
hanno il coraggio di ammetterlo fermiamo
tutto e questo è l'empatia reparti ha
quindi che aiuta che aiuta e soprattutto
l'empatia cioè la capacità di mettersi
nei panni degli altri che è una
condizione fondamentale per un un
aspetto cruciale del nostro mondo in
questo momento in grande crisi il
multilateralismo cioè cioè il condominio
del mondo cioè l'on
la precondizione per lavorare dentro
l'onu è che io accetto che anche lo
stato più piccolo del mondo che non ha
nessun potere né economico né militare
ha una sua ragione una sua ragione
d'essere quando l'onu è nato è partito
da quel principio riconoscendo che gli
stati più importanti sono più potenti
ovviamente il consiglio di sicurezza il
diritto di veto ma accettando che il
condominio del mondo deve tenere un po
conto anche di tutti e e senza onu senza
condominio del mondo
noi non siamo in grado di affrontare i
problemi globali
il clima le migrazioni il terrorismo
problemi che se uno stato li affronta da
solo può tamponare ma non li risolve
pensate alle migrazioni le migrazioni
hanno paesi di origine paesi di transito
e paesi di destinazione
i paesi di origine sono contenti se
migranti vanno meno disoccupati e gente
che manda le rimesse quindi mi dà
ricchezza hanno tutto l'interesse a
incentivare i paesi di transito come il
ciad sono paesi che prosperano sul
traffico dei migranti arrivano mangiano
dormono chiedono i passaggi con i
pulmini la mia popolazione vive su
quello i paesi di destinazione
noi siamo fra questi non li vogliono non
li vogliono più vorrebbero selezionare
quindi hanno obiettivi totalmente
diversi fra di loro ma se non si trova
un qualche
minimo comune denominatore cercando di
capire le ragioni dell'altro non si
andrà lontano
noi andiamo dal paese africani a dire ti
do mezzo milione un milione di euro per
aiutarti a casa tua
ma se non ragiono nella mente del
presidente di quel paese che se i
migranti escono di milioni ne mandano
casa 75 con le rimesse per il presidente
mi dirà sì certo
va bene senz'altro ma non farà nulla
perché c'è una logica totalmente diversa
quali sono le conclusioni le conclusioni
siamo partiti dalla l'empatia che
c'azzecca l'empatia dove la vediamo in
questo mondo dove guardando il mondo il
mondo reale
chi mi dice che l'empatia e la soluzione
di tutto vive su un altro mondo c'è un
pendolo fra chi crede che l'empatia è
una pia illusione
e chi crede che l'empatia e la panacea
la soluzione di tutto su che cosa
possiamo provare a trovare un accordo è
che l'empatia è una condizione
necessaria per aiutare il mondo a fare
meno pasticci ma non è sufficiente
c'è l'empatia serve l'empatia ma sempre
ci governeranno avranno importanza gli
interessi la supremazia e la forza ma
l'empatia è appunto una condizione
necessaria anche se non sufficiente e
come la la coltivo l'empatia e come la
distruggo l'empatia senza esaltarla ma
pensando che possa servire come la
coltivo la coltivo innanzitutto
conoscendo studiando con la curiosità la
curiosità di conoscere gli altri paesi
le loro culture per abitudine viaggiando
conoscendo intrigando mi degli altri di
ciò che è diverso
accettando il cibo i costumi non
chiudendo mi su la pasta alla norma
rispetto che il riso al risotto dalla
mia
ma accettando anche realtà diverse
quindi il primo con la curiosità il
secondo modo per coltivare l'empatia e
passare dai numeri dalle masse ai
singoli tutti noi abbiamo conosciuto il
dramma dell'olocausto ma i milioni ci
dicono poco ci hanno detto poco finché
non abbiamo conosciuto la storia e le
vicende la famiglia di anna frank
tutti noi conosciamo è il dramma delle
migrazioni
ma sono numeri fino quando non vediamo
l'immagine del piccolo highland sulle
coste della grecia e li capiamo che
potrebbe essere un bambino come nostro
nipote come nostro figlio come il figlio
dei nostri amici quindi il passare come
dice madre teresa dalle masse
all'individuo è il modo per passare dal
grigio dal buio all'empatia per le
singole persone e come si distrugge
invece l'empatia l'empatia si distrugge
quando generalizziamo l'empatia si
distrugge quando diciamo [ __ ] islamici
radicalizzati [ __ ] quando usiamo
termini che cercano di dare a delle
comunità anche vastissime un etichetta
generale e complessiva come si
distruggerà empatia si distrugge quando
esagero
nel sottolineare l'importanza del match
dell'io dell'identità nazionale
dell'identità delle tradizioni delle
culture delle radici le mie my country
first questi questo che crea noi e un
loro a prescindere è un passaggio per
distruggere l'empatia l'empatia la
creiamo quando cominciamo a dire sì i
neri i migranti sono un problema
però io conosco quello della bancarella
di è un bravo ragazzo e cambio
atteggiamento quando dico regione
musulmano è diversa noi è un problema
però quello della bancarella in fondo
che venderebbero 7 lo conosco da dieci
anni è bravo ragazzo
quando entriamo un po alla volta senza
appiattirci sull'altro
nessuno vuole questo ma a capire che
l'altro non è bianco e nero ma c'è una
zona grigia lì siamo
sulla buona strada grazie
[Applauso]